the Joe Rogan experience I don't know
you have those coaches that are like
okay guys breathe I don't want my coach
told me to breathe in the corner no I'm
like know how to breathe here right well
does that drive you crazy when you hear
corners that don't give good advice go
finish them yeah thanks get up man get
up no [ __ ]
go out there and kick his ass yeah
that's why I was lucky to have him you
know guys that pay attention to detail a
mark Ricardo man those guys are
top-notch technical yeah they're cool
they're not giving you that you know
sometimes you do you need to like
sometimes some guys I think mark got
some flack for the Marlin fight where he
was in the corner he's like your mother
raised you but you know and someone's
like why is he talking about his mom's
because he knew he didn't need technique
he needed some motivation at that point
was Marlon
too big did he lose too much weight to
get down to 35 and was he depleted or
was it a pseudo just steamroll him I
just think the moment you know I think
Marlon hit him with some good shots and
mhm he hit him with some good shots of a
cake the right hand yeah and I think the
fact that pseudo just took and kept
coming forward I think kind of just
demoralized Marlon a little bit like it
doesn't lie in my eyes pseudo was not
going to be able to take much more to
the legs oh yeah no way I thought I I
for sure and I first found I'm like this
fights not knowing the distance yeah I
thought Marlon was gonna keep chopping
at the legs but Marlon let's say who
don't close the distance and once he
lets the huto close the distance and get
a hold of him started hitting him with
knees and I was like oh Jesus Christ
yeah yeah so who does and even like I
mean Marlon it was in that Thai clinch
too and when dude Marlon knows how to
deal with Thai clinch yeah and he just
wasn't even reacting to it he's I kind
of let him hit him with the knees I felt
like home all sits like I felt like he
was just depleted it's it seemed like he
didn't have the energy to fight the kind
of fight that pseudo was well on the fun
right especially so who taught 35 right
so who do at 25 he's draining himself a
little yeah but pseudo at 35 was much
healthier yeah and just [ __ ] guys
just toughest [ __ ] man he has a winner's
behinds away I mean he's got a winner's
mind you know and his the videos that he
makes her pretty ridiculous super each
triple see come on bend the knee I mean
I guess that's you know everyone's gotta
have a stick now
I guess they do because it keeps them
out there it's it's just it's weird
because this sport is part of that right
it's like part there's it's part
promotion but it's also performance it's
like guys like Connor or the perfect
blend yeah like he's just just beat him
himself but Connors like it's
entertaining it's funny some of these
other guys man it's just a forced and
it's rough but look like Colby Covington
Colby Covington [ __ ] talked his way to a
goddamn title show yeah he really did
MEMS long but he's also very good very
you can't not be good you have song he
was off willing took they wanted to cut
him before he fought in Brazil do you
know that yeah it was last fight on his
contract he's going over there to fight
Demian Maia and he just talked mad [ __ ]
he's gonna get them home capped him he's
like yeah that was what that's what did
it I mean that's literally what did it
and then that character just took off
you go and look at the early versions of
that character he had nice suits like he
had a like a real crisp suit like Connor
would wear but then later he's got these
it's like it's part of the fun of it
yeah he's wearing [ __ ] he's it's a
magical character Rockman he he [ __ ]
figured it out
well how about Connor he's kind of made
a little 180 type flip on his person
he's still funny still you know mouthy
and stuff please not be and he seems
like he's trying to clean his image up a
little bit you think with cowboy you
think that's it
maybe this cowboy cap was kind of easy
to get along with and whatnot or mine
it's just that he's been dealing with so
much you know with the cookie fight he's
like you know you got a that proper 12
he's got a total line a little bit yes
right I mean yeah I think proper 12 is
an enormous amount of money for him I
mean he's he's making [ __ ] tons of money
I was in Vegas that [ __ ] those
billboards were everywhere yeah on cars
and [ __ ] he was sponsoring the Bellator
cage - was he yeah yeah good for him I
yeah I wonder but I also think I don't
think he felt like he needs
psychological warfare with with cowboy I
feel like he thought from the beginning
that he had a giant advantage over
cowboy yeah you know like
if you go back to an old press
conference were talking back and [ __ ] to
each other he's like his stiff as a
board right right yeah [ __ ] break in
half I think he just felt like this
fight look I could just be a nice guy
with this guy all right
but with khabib I think he felt like he
had a [ __ ] with them I felt like he felt
that he had to get khabib emotional the
same way he got although emotional but
that [ __ ] didn't work that [ __ ]
a he's a vault he look in his eyes you
just see nothing but doom yeah
[Applause]